كيف يمضي اليوم وكيف يعيش اكثر من مليوني
شخص في قطاع غزه حياتهم في خضم القصف
الاسرائيلي المتصاعد
سؤال يطرح نفسه في واجهه الاحداث جنبا الى
جنب مع القصف بكل تداعياته وانعكاساته هي
تداعيات وانعكاسات طالت الاف الاسر لا
يبدا يومهم كما ينبغي ان يبدا في اي مكان
اخر ينامون على الخوف ويستيقظون عليه
مواقف انعدم فيها الاحساس الطبيعي بالحياه
تعرضنا لموقف شديد احنا لحتى الان الاطفال
عنا بيعانوا من العديد من نوبات الهلع
بالليل يعني مفزوعين انه في قصف بنايه
اصبحت اكوام من الحجاره جراء القصف الذي
لا يميز مكانا بنايات مدمره وكان زلزالا
ضربها وسكانها في الشارع وقد اسقط في
ايديهم ومنهم من عاش الدمار مرات
في هذه البنايه تشردت خمس عائلات تجمعوا
هنا بعد قصف سابق اصبحوا الان بلا ماوى
يروي الشارع معهم القصه وقصه كثيرين غيرهم
الشوارع مرميين يعني طول الليل في الشارع
يعني قصه اخرى تخرج من وراء ابواب هذه
المتاجر المغلقه التي تركها اصحابها خوفا
من القصر القصه تحمل تفاصيل التضييق
الاقتصادي على الناس من لم يتكبد الخساره
بالقصف يتكبدها جراء توقف تجارته
امين ابو الخير صاحب مطعم سمك يقول انه
يعول عشرين نفسا لا يعلم الان ماذا يفعل
بعد توقف الحركه في مطعمه وليس امامه سوى
هذا الجلوس القلق وقد مضت عليه ايام في
هذا الحال في الاحداث احنا طبعا بنسكر هذه
كلها معبيه كلها اسماك هذه الثلاجه كلها
بتكون مليان اسماك من جميع انواع السمك
جسدت التجاره وتعطل حال الكثيرين واصبح
الالاف بلا عمل مع استمرار القصف وانعدام
الامن واي يوم بلا عمل يعني للاسري يوما
بلا مؤونه والحال يغني عن السؤال والجميع
في انتظار المجهول